Hello everyone, this is Frank Defratis, and I would like to welcome you to another broadcast of Holotalk, the Internet's Laser and Holography Broadcast, or commonly known today as a podcast.
My guest for this installment of HoloTalk is a man I greatly admire for the type of work he does in holography, and his name is John Clayer.
Now, John has a rather unusual approach to holography and the fact that he goes outside of his own laser lab and down into caves deep within the darkness, and he takes a portable system which he developed himself down into these caves and makes holograms inside the caves.
Now, this to me is absolutely fascinating.
I mean, how many holographers do we have in the world?
Quite a few.
Not as many as photographers, but there's quite a few holographers.
John is a singular holographer in the fact that I don't know of that many or any that I can recall offhand that actually has a portable system and goes make and goes to make holograms out in the world.
But John does, and it's a fascinating aspect of holographography for me, and it always has been with the work that John has done.
And it was an honor to be able to have him come and visit us last year when we were working on the Civil War holograp in Jacksonville, Florida, at Inglewood High School.
And John came from his home in Georgia to Jacksonville, Florida, and spent a day with us and the study know with the students, and he brought his uh first prototype for his uh what he calls holography camera with him and set that up and showed us how it works, and we're just totally fascinated by it.
And he has recently made some very impressive holograms, laser transmission holograms, inside uh the caves.
Now he's been doing this for years.
This isn't something that's new.
He's been doing this for years.
I mean, I think I first met John after I came onto the internet in the mid-90s, and he was already doing this.
So I left a note on uh one of his personal pages that uh it's very similar to the images that were sent back from the moon and sent back from Mars.
And I'm not exaggerating when I say that.
And one day there's going to be a rover on Mars, and it's going to be able to send back, probably via digital data, um, holographic images uh of the Martian surface and rocks.
And to me, I mean, to the rest of the world, that's going to be totally fascinating, especially if those holograms are synthesized, you know, uh, via digital technology into actual holograms and possibly even reproduced on magazine covers for everyone to see.
They'll be totally fascinated saying, Wow, this is a rock from Mars, you know, and I'm seeing this as a hologram in front of me on this magazine cover, and it's going uh to me, it's going to be, well, you know, this man has been doing this for years, you know, this is nothing new.
I just hope the world doesn't forget what John Clare not only has done, but what he's doing right now, at this moment, in our own life lifetimes, uh, as you're sitting here listening to this.
So, without further ado, let me turn the interview over to uh John Claire.
Now, this interview was conducted back in December, right before, immediately before I took a break for the uh holiday season, and uh basically I had to edit it, which I have done, and now I had to do an introduction, which I'm now completing with this.
But it's been long overdue.
I know John's been waiting for it.
I've been waiting for it.
Uh now John is a rather soft spoken man.
He's not as outgoing and flamboyant as you find me when I'm out somewhere or on the show here.
Um so uh he's rather quiet in the interview, so there's I tried to, you know, boost his voice as much as possible, but uh he's very humble in what he has done, and uh he's a wonderful guy to know.
So w without saying any more, I will turn the interview over to uh we'll turn you over to the interview with John Clare, and as always, thank you for listening to Holo Talk.
Here's John Clare.
Hello, John, how are you?
It's Frank Defratis.
Yeah, hey Frank, how you doing?
You doing good tonight?
Yeah.
Terrific.
Another Monday morning coming up.
Great, yeah, I know.
Well, it's good to have you on the show.
And I know a lot of listeners are going to be looking forward to hearing all it is that you're going to say about doing your cave holography.
I was wondering if we could start off with that, telling the listeners a little bit about what you do with cave holography and also some of the new discoveries you've made with your new pieces of equipment.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, well, cave holography is something I've been interested in for very long time, almost as long as I've been caving, which is real long.
Uh guess I started uh caving back in the late sixties or something, and ever since I've uh known known about holography I've um think about cave holography and I have tried it you know way back in the seventies with the uh cruder uh helium neon lasers and power supplies I had back then didn't have much success and uh uh a few years uh ago I done it again with another helium neon laser uh doing just a simple uh one beam reflection holograms with uh you know nicer power supplies we have nowadays.
Had a great success with that and uh I've been trying to do the two beam transmission holograms 'cause I'm just impressed with the image you have in a transmission hologram.
It's uh you can get a image that's actually bigger than the plate, uh a transmission hologram as you know is like a window that you're looking through at a big scene behind it.
Yeah, exactly.
Uhhuh and it's the image is always nice and um how would I say uh sharp.
Mm-hmm.
As long as you're using a laser Yes.
Uh tra play it back.
Uh but I hadn't had a whole lot of luck uh making transmission hologram until just a few weeks ago.
Uh there were I would uh try to set up in the lab at home and seemed to work okay and I go to the cave and try it and for some reason uh I was getting very uh weak images.
What do you think the problem was there?
Um I I'm trying to figure out I I thought, well, maybe the cave just inherently isn't stable enough and maybe you know it's just foolish to uh try it and uh uh, you know, 'cause uh doing it you have had some luck doing holograms in caves, right?
Yeah, right.
Yeah, the one beam uh reflection.
But I guess you can probably do a one beam reflection just about any place probably.
Um just minimum uh stability requirements.
And then uh like I said, if just a few weeks ago I finally had some good luck at it.
Uh um I was using plates this time instead of film.
I see.
So uh plates I guess are just a lot more stable.
A lot more expensive too.
Yeah.
Um so I guess over to Thanksgiving weekend uh shot a few in this uh cave in North Georgia and uh came home and developed them and got, you know, some meat yogurt results.
I mean they were better than I did before.
And then uh went back again this past weekend and did it again and uh I guess just made longer exposures and I'm very happy with the results this time.
Yeah, and it's uh the pictures that you had sent is from this uh recent outing, is that correct?
A recent what?
The recent uh trip to the caves.
That's the picture you sent this time.
Yeah.
And um I'm using a more compact apparatus that I had before the other uh thing I had everything on a breadboard, uh 'cause I started out using a spatial filter for the reference beam.
And uh Did you run into problems doing that?
Well you know, a space filter's for snicketing no matter what, yeah.
And when you're in a nasty environment like a cave and all and messing around with it, it's just all that much more trouble.
Yeah, some people could lose their mind trying to f figure out a spatial filter.
Yeah.
That was a but uh I had uh done other experiments with fiber optics, uh and I found that uh with this uh green laser, the DP S S type uh laser.
It's a coherent three fifteen is the uh exact brand, uh but he has an extremely long coherence length and uh so running it through a multi mode fiber, even if the fiber does scramble it up, apparently when you start out with hundreds of feet of coherence, even if you scrambled up down to what, maybe ten feet of coherence or something you still get a c decent coherence out of the end of the fiber.
So I was just using that to uh after a little uh Edmund beam splitter, um, bringing it up and around and uh just what comes out of the end of the fiber just comes out as a cone, you know, just yeah.
It's got a little bit of its own mode pattern in it, but after you bleach the hologram you don't even notice it.
No kidding.
That's good.
And when you look and when you look at that hologram it's almost like you're back in that cave again, isn't it?
Yeah.
At that sp you know, particular spot.
Mhm.
Yeah.
It's uh weird thing about using a fiber optic, uh when you develop the film before you bleach it, w uh it looks like somebody just splattered paint on it.
It's yeah, I see.
Oh man, this is hopeless.
This uh can't be a good hologram.
And after you bleach it, that's amazing.
Yeah.
Now you fiber also scrambles up the uh polarization of the laser too.
But yet you still get bright results, right?
Yeah.
And then I've also been uh using uh what's called engineered diffuser to spread my beam out and I've tried on all kinds of different lenses, all little ball lenses all trying to spread it out enough to uh light up the whole scene.
And then I tried a opal diffusing glass, which makes a nice even illumination.
But it's spreads out so much that you know, there's just not enough reflecting back to uh expose the hologram in a reasonable amount of time.
Yeah, it spreads out pretty quick over short distance, doesn't it?
Yeah.
So these engineering diffusers, uh imagine there's several different companies that make 'em, but uh one I'm using is by a company called Luminate.
L U M I N I T I think, Luminate.
Uh they're called light shaping diffusers.
And they sell 'em uh different diffusion patterns.
Uh some of 'em uh diffuse into a round shape, some of them into an elliptical shape.
Uh so it's amazing how they can shape the beam by using those sheets.
Yeah.
They it's apparently uh I don't know exactly how they do it, but they their literature shows, you know, m micro photographs of the surface and it's uh little tiny um like bumps, uh and I guess they shape the sh the bumps in a certain direction, uh to cause the the light to go whichever way they want.
I guess it's uh diffraction of some sort.
Um Do you plan on going back into the cave and doing a series of these holograms?
I'm not down here this weekend.
I you know, occasionally I do have to s do some things at home and uh yeah probably next weekend I'll go back down again caving or something.
I do, you know a few days every month anyhow.
It would be great if you could get an exhibit of this stuff.
Mm-hmm.
I would love to see these pieces.
I I'm always fascinated with what it is that you do.
You know, going into caves and doing cave holography.
That's that's John Claire.
That that's your own field.
Well I'm just hoping some other people might uh you know get inspired by this and not necessarily you know do it in a cave, but you know, try something else, you know, find something else out in nature or something that's available that maybe on a dark night the you can make a hologram of uh some weird rock formations or something maybe some historical thing of some sort.
Or maybe just uh put a tent over it to make it dark, whatever.
Yeah.
Uh Michael Harrison's another person uh I know he lives down Texas and I think he tried doing uh some holograms on a beach one time, I guess shells or something.
I don't think he had too good a success with it.
Yeah, I think I think there's been a few people that have actually gone out and made a few outdoor hologram.
But what you do is almost like a little field unto yourself.
I mean they they go out, they try their hologram, they make their hologram and then they go back to whatever else it was they were doing and experimenting with and moving on to other things, but you've been doing this for so many years that this is basically almost like your own field.
Well, I just don't want to give up on it and uh uh caving is something I love to do, holography's something I love to do, so I'm just fortunate that I got two interests that you know just managed to come together.
What what would your plans for the future be with this?
Anything?
Uh make better ones, um How about larger ones?
You s for see yourself doing perhaps eight by tens.
Yeah.
Uh right now I what I'm doing I think is uh four inch by four inch, it's just because the plates I had uh um I've cut 'em down, that was just a convenient size, but uh standard plates are four by five.
Now, how did four by four make 'em more convenient?
Um the apparatus I put together, the platinum that I'm using to hold the film.
Yeah.
Okay, um I looked around thinking, uh, what can I use to you know, a nice stable piece of material to put the film against and I found a um I guess a cover from a electrical box.
Okay.
Four inch by four inch.
I see.
So I uh So you cut glass built over it and uh incorporated it into my apparatus.
Did you cut glass plates down to the four by four?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, uh I bought some uh plates from Giang that were uh some odd size.
They weren't even eight by ten, they were uh some strange size and that's why I got a deal on 'em, um I think somebody ordered 'em and then, you know got the special order but didn't pay for 'em or something, so I came back with 'em, so I I think they're old as can be too.
I think they're manufactured in two thousand three and here it is almost two thousand nine.
I'm using 'em and yeah.
So it says something about the VRP plates that they have a long shelf life.
I've never had any difficulties working with holographic plates that were past their expiration date.
There's always a way that you can figure out to work with them, whether it's a pre-soak or whatever it is, increasing exposure to compensate for the age.
But you can get good holograms out of plates that are even more than ten years old, easy.
Yeah, well I got some uh stuff around here that's probably more than ten years old.
Um, uh talking about the reflection or the transmission holograms, uh another uh nice thing nowadays is uh little red diodes are cheap.
So used to be a problem with uh transmission holograms is how you gonna play it back.
Well you're gonna have to use a laser.
Well, nowadays, you know a red laser doesn't cost any more than uh a flashlight, you know.
Mm-hmm.
So you're you're shooting them in green and now you're going to illuminate them with red.
Right.
Okay.
Yeah, I've done that myself.
I find that to be pretty convenient 'cause I have a hundred milliwatt green here.
And I've sh I've shot some green holograms and then just for convenience, illuminate them even with just a laser pointer.
Uhhuh.
And it doesn't ni necessarily have to be any type of a non mode hopping type of diode or anything.
You just need the light to illuminate the holograms.
So you can use any diode that's out there.
Right, yeah, it doesn't matter if it mode hops or not, you just use it as illumination.
Um another nice thing about the little red diodes is they just naturally come out spread already and clean as can be.
Yeah.
Um see any other questions about the cave holography.
Mm, I don't think I have any other questions.
When how l how many years have you been doing this now?
Oh When did you what year did you shoot your first cave hologram?
Well my attempts were way back in the nineteen seventies but actually uh having any success was uh more recently it's probably uh some I can't remember exact date, it was sometime in the nineteen ninety so uh I did the uh the one beam uh reflections Okay.
Um anyhow the uh light shaping diffuser is I think the uh trick now with this.
Because um when you're throwing the energy out and you need to have a certain amount come back, uh you can control with these things you know, how much of an area you're covering.
Yeah.
So start with a hundred milliwatts if s if you spread it out over uh hundred eighty degrees you're not getting anything back is this if you're shooting oh a beam of uh only thirty degrees wide you do have quite a bit coming back.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah the pictures that you that you sent were uh very bright.
Mhm.
Now what was that, a rock formation?
It looks almost like i as if it could be one of those underwater photographs too.
Yeah.
That could be an option for you getting involved with this and make making it uh watertight and doing something underwater.
Well it's uh one of the pictures I sent you, uh I think I pointed out that uh it was the thing to the right there, uh we call it a uh drapery formation.
It's just the way the limestone uh, you know, formed over the eons that that uh made a thing called drapery.
Mm-hmm.
I thought it was just a interesting thing to take a picture of it, uh there are much more beautiful things in caves.
It's just uh I'm experimenting right now and that's a cave that's easy to get in well, relatively easy to get in.
I still have to repel into it, but yeah love to have one I could just park my car and walk into.
But then that wouldn't be caving anymore would it?
Now have you sh have you displayed these to any other cave enthusiasts and w and if you have, what has their reaction been well I I just shot 'em uh last Sunday and uh there's only uh three people uh other's my wife uh you now that's seen 'em as uh uh the person that owns the cave and uh two other cavers.
I'm I'm a big fan of yours.
I like what it is that you do.
Well I appreciate that.
And uh I f I find it really interesting.
I've I've always f found it interesting.
I'll see if I can't send along one of my holograms to you to take a look at the real thing.
Well I'll tell you what you you send a hologram to me and I'll make sure that when I go out on the road I'll make sure that I take it with me and other people see it and give you credit that you did it.
Alright, thank you.
We'll get a lot of different people from a lot of different parts of the United States take a look at it.
Alright, you give me more reason to go caving next week.
Be safe though, be safe All right, we'll talk you later.
Alright John, thank you so much.
All right bye